I know you're single dating men are men
intimidated by you
do you think maybe but I really wouldn't
want to waste any time on a guy that is
easily intimidated by me I mean there's
more than too many things in life than
me so right that stopped you already
then you're just saving my time right
which is good but you need a confident
guy you need a you need a confidence
definitely confident tall red hair
[Applause]
[Music]
this thing comes off as easy as it went
on it really the audience is like no I'm
really not gonna leave my wife we're
just gonna mess around
I really like I like the idea of being
completely honest with you I like the
idea of a strong woman who could just
beat the [ __ ] out of me I think that's
sexy I really do I mean there's a lot of
guys out there though look for a girl
that's less to feel like he's more and I
want to find a guy that wants to be on
my level and not want somebody make him
feel more secure with himself yes yes I
know exactly what you're talking about
well Rhonda and I are going to dinner
now
you